y
[Música]
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski visitó busca el mandatario
sostiene que allí ocurrió un genocidio
por los cientos de cadáveres que
encontraron tras la retirada rusa oscuro
insiste en que todo es una fabricación
de ucrania
el calentamiento global podría
incrementar en más de 3 grados celsius
si las políticas ambientales no cambian
así lo reveló el panel climático de la
onu en su más reciente reporte aunque da
luces de esperanza al decir que el
planeta tiene el potencial de disminuir
a la mitad las emisiones para 2030
migración y seguridad son dos de los
temas determinantes de las
presidenciales de francia este domingo
ya no solo los candidatos de derecha y
extrema derecha hablan de reformas sino
que 10 de los 12 aspirantes al elíseo
quieren hacer consultas sobre las
políticas migratorias
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
gusto volver a estar con ustedes y
comenzamos esta emisión en ucrania el
presidente de ese país volodymyr
selenski visitó la localidad de butch a
donde la alcaldía de este suburbio a las
afueras de kiev denuncia que encontraron
más de 300 cuerpos en fosas comunes tras
la retirada de las tropas rusas el
mandatario estaba con traje militar y
chaleco antibalas y aseguró que se ha
vuelto más difícil negociar con rusia
desde que ucrania se ha vuelto
consciente del alcance de las
atrocidades que atribuyó al ejército de
moscú selenski además denunció que
muchas se cometieron crímenes de guerra
que serán reconocidos mundialmente como
un genocidio
estos son crímenes de guerra y serán
reconocidos por el mundo como genocidio
ustedes están aquí pueden ver lo que
sucedió sabemos que miles de personas
fueron asesinadas y torturadas
desgarradas y violadas y asesinatos de
niños
naciones unidos se pronunció y afirmó
que lo ocurrido en lucha podría ser un
crimen de guerra y una grave violación a
los derechos humanos así lo advirtió hoy
listos el pues era de la oficina de
derechos humanos de la onu este
organismo pidió investigar los hechos
previamente la organización human rights
wacht recopiló testimonios que probarían
que por lo menos cinco civiles fueron
ejecutados por los rusos en lucha y
también tienen reportes de violaciones
sexuales en las ciudades de chernin
kharkiv y kiev por su parte de la unión
europea está lista para enviar
investigadores y buscar pruebas de
crímenes de guerra en ucrania según dijo
hoy ursula von der leyen presidenta de
la comisión europea
y varios líderes occidentales han
condenado la muerte de civiles en lucha
el mandatario estadounidense joe biden
el presidente francés emmanuel mayo y el
canciller alemán olaf scholz respaldan a
selenski en que esto es un crimen de
guerra y polonia pidió a los mandatarios
europeos que sean más contundentes con
rusia mientras que moscú niega ser
responsable de la matanza y sostiene que
todo es una fabricación de los tanto
ucrania como rusia pidieron una sesión
en el consejo de seguridad para discutir
lo que ocurrió aunque moscú sostiene que
reino unido ya ha bloqueo de nuevo esta
sesión luís muñoz y manuel acá no nos
cuentan más
civiles maniatados ejecutados con
disparos a quemarropa y una gran fosa
común las autoridades denunciaron que en
dicha localidad a 40 kilómetros de kiev
que estuvo control ruso hasta hace poco
fueron encontrados 300 cuerpos 50
habrían sido asesinados de forma
extrajudicial según versiones ucranianas
rusia enfrenta una nueva ola de condena
internacional
todos estamos extremadamente
conmocionado si luego es condenado con
la mayor de las fuerzas y en segundo
lugar está claro que hay indicios claros
de crímenes de guerra era el ejército
ruso el que estaba en lucha sin embargo
para algunos los nuevos rechazos se
tratan sólo de palabras vacías piden
mayor contundencia al presidente macro
señor presidente macro no cuántas veces
ha negociado con vladimir putin que ha
logrado no se debe dialogar ni negociar
con criminales los criminales deben ser
combatidos
de voto de negocios
negociar y
ver se situarán
eeuu por su parte aseguró que vendrán
más sanciones y que reunirán todos los
detalles de lo sucedido para llevarle un
juicio por crímenes de guerra
ustedes recordarán que fui criticado por
llamar criminal de guerra a vladimir
putin bueno vi lo que pasó en lucha esto
lo justifica es un criminal
la versión del kremlin es completamente
distinta el trago esto
por lo que hemos visto las imágenes de
vídeo en muchos aspectos uno no puede
confiar en ellas porque es obvio
nuestros expertos del ministerio de
defensa han identificado signos de
falsificación los hechos y la cronología
de los eventos tampoco respaldan la
autenticidad de este alivio en este
vídeo para luego mañana
el ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
serguéi lávrov entregó más detalles
sobre el supuesto montaje
russo se retiró por completo en esta
ciudad el 30 de marzo el 31 de marzo de
estos elementos que todo está mejor los
días después vimos conoció la [__] en
escena
con fines
rusia y ucrania pidieron revisar el caso
en el consejo de seguridad de las
naciones unidas a pesar de que rusia
niega haber matado a civiles en busán
alemania tomó represalias por lo que
ocurrió en este suburbio de kiev es que
el gobierno alemán anunció hoy que
expulsará a 40 diplomáticos rusos de la
embajada de berlín la ministra de
asuntos exteriores anna-lena haber box
agregó que ellos son consideradas
personas 'non grata' porque día a día
trabajan en contra de la libertad y la
cohesión social lituania también expulsó
al embajador ruso y cerró el consulado
de rusia en la ciudad de klaipeda el
ministerio exteriores ruso dice que
pronto responderá a las medidas
y otra de las noticias en europa son las
elecciones en los comicios del domingo
hungría y serbia se eligieron a sus
mandatarios un factor que comparten el
primer ministro húngaro viktor orbán y
el presidente serbio aleksandar vucic es
que ambos son cercanos al kremlin de
hecho el mandatario ruso vladimir putin
los felicito tras su victoria y dijo que
esperaba fortalecer las alianzas algo
que la unión europea mira con
preocupación en medio de la guerra en
ucrania
el líder de la unión europea más cercano
al kremlin volvió a ganar las elecciones
en hungría la victoria del
ultranacionalista viktor orbán trajo
consigo la felicitación del presidente
vladimir putin
pese a una situación internacional
difícil el futuro desarrollo de los
vínculos bilaterales y de cooperación
corresponderá a los intereses de los
pueblos de rusia y hungría
orbán lidera una democracia y liberal
para muchos inspirada en algunos
elementos en rusia y aunque apoyó las
cuatro rondas de sanciones de la unión
europea contra moscú no colaboró con
armas ni permitió que los cargamentos de
material militar para ucrania de otros
socios pasaran por su territorio marc
busca la cta la angostura rival
mcchrystal y ahora hemos tenido que
luchar contra las fuerzas más grandes la
izquierda en casa la izquierda
internacional los burócratas de bruselas
todas las organizaciones del imperio
solos los medios de comunicación
internacionales y finalmente el
presidente ucraniano nunca habíamos
tenido tantos oponentes antes
[Aplausos]
y
además celebró elecciones serbia el
populista alexander but chip fue
reelegido putin también lo felicito
espero que su trabajo como jefe de
estado continúe ayudando a fortalecer
las relaciones de asociación estratégica
eso por supuesto beneficiará a los
pueblos hermanos de rusia y serbia
pese a solicitar su adhesión a la unión
europea
serbia mantiene lazos económicos con
rusia pero también culturales e
históricos el 83% de los serbios
consideran a moscú como un amigo rico
cucsh mixto trataremos de mantener
nuestras relaciones no sólo correctas
sino también amistosas con la federación
rusa de la mejor manera posible con
acceso a los éxitos de los aliados de
vladimir putin marcan un nuevo camino
para europa donde hungría y serbia se
debatirán entre permanecer junto al
bloque europeo o acercarse más a moscú
sobre todo ahora con la guerra en
ucrania en pleno curso en francia la
noticia es por las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 10 de abril
la inmigración parecía ser el centro del
debate pero ahora está eclipsado por la
guerra en ucrania el poder adquisitivo y
la crisis sanitaria sin embargo no deja
de ser una de las prioridades y es que
todos los candidatos al elíseo y ya no
sólo los de derecha y extrema derecha
hablan en sus discursos de reformas
cambios totales o continuidad en la
integración ángela gutiérrez nos cuenta
que proponen veamos el siguiente informe
de nuestra serie hacia las elecciones
del domingo
francia vive hoy una inmigración sin
precedentes actualmente hay 7 millones
de inmigrantes el 10 3 por ciento de la
población total la cifra más alta el
número y porcentaje de la población que
el país ha registrado que proponen los
candidatos para enfrentar este desafío
referéndum 10 de los 12 candidatos
quieren hacer esta consulta sobre los
temas clave del país incluida la
migración pero dos se focalizan en el
tema tanto marín depende el partido
reagrupación nacional como eric fémur
del partido la reconquista ambos de
extrema derecha proponen un referendo
para ponerle fin al reagrupamiento
familiar y al derecho europeo por encima
del francés además de endurecer el
acceso a la nacionalidad reformular el
control de las fronteras y la creación
por parte de ese muro del ministerio de
la re migración para expulsar a un
millón de extranjeros derecho de asilo
todos los candidatos quieren
garantizarlo pero con ajustes el
presidente candidato de manuel macrón de
la república en marcha quiere facilitar
la expulsión de las personas a las que
se les haya negado asilo y mantener las
cuotas de inmigrantes una reforma en su
mandato que para muchos fue un giro a la
derecha de su política migratoria
lepe en ese muro y la candidata
conservadora valérie pécresse de los
republicanos quieren que todas las
solicitudes se hagan desde el exterior
la expulsión de condenados extranjeros 5
de los 12 candidatos manifiestan en sus
programas estar de acuerdo con la
expulsión de delincuentes extranjeros de
pene pécresse macro ni se murió este
último propone expulsar también a los
fichados como radicales islamistas lucha
contra el islam radical y el terrorismo
macro mantiene la idea del cierre de
asociaciones y mezquitas radicales y en
firme la llamada ley contra el
separatismo aprobada en su quinquenio la
misma que quiere derogar el candidato de
izquierda a jean luc mélenchon de la
francia insumisa por considerarla anti
republicana y tildada por le ven como
insuficiente ella prohibirá de raíz la
práctica y la difusión pública de la
ideología islamista
quienes entran a francia y quienes no un
desafío en las propuestas de los
candidatos que tratan de responder a
este fenómeno migratorio al que ahora se
suma la ola de refugiados ucranianos
esta década será crucial para combatir
el calentamiento global así lo advirtió
el nuevo reporte de la onu realizado por
el panel intergubernamental de expertos
sobre el cambio climático el ipcc los
analistas plantean que existe el
potencial para reducir a la mitad las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
para el año 2030 algo que dicen que se
puede lograr por ejemplo plantando
bosques podés estimulando el uso de
energías fósiles sin embargo la
advertencia es clara si las políticas no
se fortalecen el calentamiento global
podría aumentar 3,2 grados celsius para
el año 2025 con lo cual no se cumpliría
la meta del acuerdo de parís de limitar
el calentamiento a 1,5 grados celsius we
are on peso global warming estamos en
camino hacia el calentamiento global más
del doble del límite de 15 grados
acordado en parís algunos líderes
gubernamentales y empresariales están
diciendo una cosa pero asia en pocas
palabras están mintiendo y los
resultados serán catastróficos esta es
una emergencia climática los científicos
del clima advierten que ya estamos
peligrosamente cerca de un punto de
inflexión que podría conducir a impactos
climáticos en cascada e irreversible
significativo el cual met inpex en
noticias económicas los turcos se
enfrentan la inflación más alta que ha
habido en 20 años los datos oficiales
publicados este lunes muestran que la
inflación anual al consumidor saltó al
61 por ciento un incremento que está
ligado con la subida de los precios de
la energía y las materias primas
situación que empeoró por la guerra en
ucrania desde estambul adriana rocha
nostra de todos los detalles
auspiciada por el auge del precio del
petróleo y del trigo por la guerra de
ucrania y por la crisis económica que
turquía viene arrastrando día desde
finales y mira desde 2021 la inflación
se están desbocando en turquía según ha
explicado esta misma mañana el instituto
oficial de estadística la cifra
interanual de inflación de este 2022
estaría por en torno al 61 por ciento
una cifra muy grande casi desbocada y
que estaría ya más por encima y sería
superior a las cifras que se llegaron
récord en turquía a finales de la década
de los noventa y principios de los 2000
que sirvieron a una crisis económica que
utilizó el actual presidente turco recep
tayyp erdogán para conseguir el poder en
ese momento era el alcalde de estambul y
no era una figura muy reconocida en todo
el país sin embargo la situación en
turquía podría ser muchísimo más grave
que lo que es ese 61% de inflación
podría marcar y es que según estudios
independientes de estadísticas está
cifra estaría la cifra real de esta
inflación sería más del doble de lo que
señala el gobierno según un estudio
independiente podría ser que la
inflación la inflación real en turquía
estuviese en torno al 40 algo que
realmente casa con lo que se vive cada
día en las calles de turquía en los
mercados donde los precios de los
alimentos también del petróleo y del
alcohol están multiplicándose a cada mes
que pasa
twitter tiene un nuevo accionista y es
nada más y nada menos que el
multimillonario y lo en más que el
director de tesla reveló que ya tiene el
92 por ciento de las acciones de la
compañía tecnológica y que las compró
por casi 3 mil millones de dólares ahora
nadie tiene más porcentaje de la empresa
que él la compra llega luego de que más
que dijera que tenía pensado crear una
nueva plataforma de redes sociales y
cuestionará a twitter por su compromiso
con la libertad de expresión
hasta aquí las noticias siguen con
france24
[Música]